los combates por la población de soledad
continúan en esta región según ha
informado tanto el Ministerio de defensa
ucraniano como también algunas Fuentes
que están en esta región del Don vasca
además dicen que los últimos días no
solamente ha habido pérdidas humanas
sino bastantes heridos de lado y lado
hoy este Ministerio ucraniano informaba
de 100 hombres de las fuerzas rusas que
habrían muerto en un ataque con misiles
y esto sucede también y viene respaldado
por uno de los videos que publicaron en
una de sus cuentas de las redes sociales
y esto llega en un momento en que el
Ministerio de defensa ruso ha anunciado
el nombramiento del General Valery
como el comandante de las fuerzas
conjuntas en un cambio bastante
estratégico ya Qué hace solamente tres
meses habían nombrado quien ocupaba a
este cargo hasta hoy el general sergey
King que ahora pasa a ser parte de esos
tres comandantes que están bajo el cargo
de este comandante que tuvo un papel
bastante importante cuando el presidente
Vladimir Putin anunció la invasión a
Ucrania el pasado 24 de febrero Y se
cree que esto hace también parte de la
estrategia del presidente Putin de
continuar con una ofensiva o por lo
menos presionar a una nueva ofensiva que
sería tanto en las zonas de la provincia
de lujánse en el don vas como también
podría eventualmente ser por el norte
por la frontera de velarrusia aunque
esto los analistas dicen que es mucho
menos probable